[Music]
so far in this course we've seen some of
the remarkable ways anthropologists
explore the origins and diversity of
humankind and if there's one thing we've
learned is that our genetics our biology
and even the archaeological record they
all converge on one anthropological
truth despite our physical and cultural
differences we are one human race but
wait just a minute if that's true why
did the last US census form that I
filled out asked me to identify my race
and they gave you and me multiple
choices right there's there's colors
like white and black geographic regions
like Asian and Pacific Islander and heck
if you look at the ways the US Census
Bureau has categorized races over time
there used to be religion races like
Hindu linguistic ones too like
spanish-speaking they list just about
everything under the Sun well except for
one thing the human race so what is it
are there multiple races or are our
biological anthropology friends correct
when they say there's only one race the
human race today is our capstone
discussion for part 1 of our course
we're going to use anthropology to
unpack enduring ambiguities between race
skin color and biology first we'll see
how anthropology itself has been rather
confused about the race concept and then
we'll see how anthropologist eventually
came to understand that biologically
speaking races nothing but a social
construct I mean we literally made it up
it has nothing to do with skin color and
geography but the story's a little more
complicated than that so let's get right
to it from the very beginning
anthropologists have been thinking about
this thing we
call race and we struggled with it from
day one
through biological anthropology we've
come a long way from the days when we
thought race biology and skin color
we're all one in the same but that said
this project is far from complete
anthropologists have been working on the
question of race for well over a century
and we've still got a lot to learn
archaeologist Charles Orser for example
look back at how archaeologists have
understood race over the decades and he
found that many of them tend to confuse
race with ethnicity and socioeconomic
status and his groundbreaking research
no pun intended
helps us separate biological versus
cultural constructions of race and we'll
return to that question at the end of
our lecture but first let's look back to
the roots of this issue let's see how
and why anthropologists archaeologists
included have had so much trouble coming
to terms with this concept of race let's
start at the beginning anthropology's
earliest version of this thing called
race as we discussed in previous
lectures Darwin's theory of natural
selection was a seductive idea and it
formalized a testable and correctable
answer to the question of our human
origins and his scientific approach it
can't tell us why there's life on this
planet but it did provide a compelling
answer to the question of how once there
was life on this planet we became human
actually his book On the Origin of
Species
it didn't exclusively focus on human
origins
his theory explained how all species
emerged anyway in the early days of
anthropology Darwin's ideas about the
biology of evolution proved so
convincing that a lot of leading
thinkers of the time they started to
apply this idea far beyond the scope of
biology folks like Herbert Spencer they
argued that just as biological organisms
evolved from simple single-cell
organisms to more complex ones like you
and me that human cultures they also
evolved from simple societies to highly
complex ones and there
certian was clear humans evolve
culturally from savage to civilized and
this idea of social evolution or social
Darwinism as Spencer described it it
became a popular explanation for the
diversity of humankind across the globe
think about this Darwin's book comes out
in the mid-1800s just as the world he's
living in grows smaller and smaller I
mean as the close of the transatlantic
slave trade transitioned into the dawn
of European empires people in Darwin's
age were exposed to new and diverse
world cultures and inspired by Darwin's
ideas on biological evolution social
Darwinist used evolution as a way to
explain human diversity and to classify
people and cultures across the globe
humans who lived in small simple
societies like a single-cell organism
they were deemed less evolved than those
who lived in complex ones with white
houses supreme courts and microbreweries
but this was the dominant idea of
scientists of the era they literally
split the world into culture grades from
savage to barbarian and civilized and
when you compare living in a mud hut
right to life in a two-story suburban
home with satellite internet this idea
it almost feels intuitive so as a
scientific community assured in this
idea of social Darwinism the idea spread
widely because it helped make sense of
the seemingly limitless human diversity
on our planet I mean suddenly it became
easy to explain why some people were
entering the so-called modern world with
industrial factories powerful trains and
upper-class values while others were
stuck in the past those who were further
along on that evolutionary path not only
had superior biology but that advanced
biology those were the foundations for
advanced civilization essentially
biology and culture were an
interconnected and inseparable entity
and the idea of race emerged as an
all-encompassing term to describe these
vast human differences so from our
physical appearance our geography and
our
religious traditions they were all
functions of our biology and to track
and make sense of all this human
diversity we use the idea of multiple
races so the differences that European
saw in humans from Africa or Asia were
attributed to the fact that we all come
from distinct lineages which we called
races now upon reflection many thinkers
further developed this idea of human
races and they did so to the extreme
that proponents of this way of thinking
coined and used the term white man's
burden to describe the idea that white
men had the moral obligation to use
their advanced state to uplift
non-whites the world over I mean
essentially
the concept of the white man's burden
was used to justify the colonization of
the non-white world consider this it's
an excerpt from Rudyard Kipling's 1899
poem white man's burden
it clearly embraces the idea of moral
uplift through imperialism take up the
white man's burden send forth the best
you breed go bind your sons to exile to
serve your captives need to wait in
heavy harness on fluttered folk and wild
your new cot sullen people's half devil
half child take up the white man's
burden and it continues these so-called
half devil half child people of the
world they were seen as slightly less
human and the concept of race helped
early anthropologists classify people
and their unique biological heritage
some races were ahead of others and you
know what even the US Supreme Court
agreed in 1896 the court heard the case
Plessy versus Ferguson in which the
justices considered whether or not the
Constitution allowed for discrimination
based on white versus non-white races
and what did the justices determine well
and a seven to one ruling the court held
that if nature created people and races
that were not equal the Constitution
could do nothing to change that and as a
result Plessy
Furguson cemented race-based segregation
as fully legal in a country where all
men are created equal they didn't
question that idea that there are
multiple unequal and biological races
they accepted inequality as a biological
outcome and no piece of paper not even
the US Constitution could change that
this idea a gained favor as a neat and
clean explanation for human diversity
and the world order with whites on top
and seemed to confirm this ideas fact I
mean the idea was so compelling that the
US government and corporate sectors
joined forces to make use of this idea
in hopes of purifying the human race I
mean after all if humans could breed
hogs and horses to new levels of fitness
and strength why wouldn't we apply these
same methodologies to improve human
stocks believe it or not they tried with
millions of dollars of support from the
wealthiest families and foundations like
Rockefeller Carnegie and the Harriman's
and more special research centers were
built to find solutions to this white
man's burden and in 1904 for example the
station for experimental evolution it
was established at Cold Spring Harbor on
Long Island and researchers at this
Institute were charged with identifying
ways to prevent defective germ plasm the
biological and primitive remnants of our
savage past from spreading any further
and it's it's the eugenics creed that
helps clarify this mission and I'll
quote I believe that I am the trustee of
the germ plasm that I carry that this
has passed on to me through thousands of
generations before me and that I
betrayed the trust if that germ plasm
being good I so apt as to jeopardize it
with its excellent possibilities or from
motives of personal convenience to
unduly limit offspring the researchers
at the SAE not only developed a series
of recommendations on how to proceed
with this project they also started to
identify family lines in the New York
New Jersey and New England area that
were tainted by criminality mental
disorder
and physical deformities and the idea
was simple to find a way to limit the
reproduction of what they deemed to be
defective human germ plasm shockingly
their official recommendations included
lethal chambers and that's their words
not mine
as the most effective solution but they
advise policy makers and others that the
u.s. population was not really ready to
accept this approach
so instead less revolting strategies
were unleashed namely marriage and
sterilization laws in 1907 for example
the state of Indiana enacted
sterilization laws to make sure
criminals and other undesirables could
not pass on their defective humanity to
other generations and in 1927 the
Supreme Court actually upheld a Virginia
statute that promoted compulsory
sterilization of the so called unfit and
in the majority opinion for that case
Chief Justice Oliver Wendell Holmes
declared quote three generations of
imbeciles is enough actually early on
this social Darwinist movement was
championed by Darwin's cousin Francis
Galton who labeled this race improvement
project eugenics and with eugenics
research centers at major US
universities all the way from Yale to
Stanford it was actually California that
most wholeheartedly embraced the
sterilization idea as the best bet for
improving the human stock and believe it
or not in first ten years of
sterilization laws California alone
sterilized nearly 10,000 people nearly
half of whom were women deemed
passionate or bad girls the idea of
applying eugenics to improve humankind
spread far beyond US borders and was
embraced by many including well Adolf
Hitler and his Nazi Party in fact when
Nazi war criminals were tried in
Nuremberg they actually cited the words
of US eugenics leaders and chief justice
Oliver Wendell Holmes to defend their
genocide elections because in their eyes
they were simply applying science to
eliminate what they saw is defective
human germ plasm
let me return to Chief Justice Holmes
majority opinion from the 1927 case I
mentioned a moment ago because I think
his words demonstrate just how pervasive
in public these ideas were Holmes wrote
it is better for all the world if
instead of waiting to execute degenerate
offspring for crime or to let them
starve for their imbecility society can
prevent those who are manifestly unfit
from continuing their kind
fortunately Holmes perspective and the
eugenics project in the in general it
began to lose ground in the u.s. in the
1930s and 40s but of course this was
precisely the time when Nazi Germany was
slaughtering millions of Jews
homosexuals and anyone else with the
potential for polluting humanity's
biological future so how did we get past
this obscene application of biology and
human difference well it took decades to
unmask the pseudo scientific foundations
of this movement but all along there
were researchers and others searching
for more valid explanations for human
diversity and their work it culminated
in ideas that now allow us to see the
difference between so-called race or
ethnicity with things like criminality
and poverty and what saved anthropology
as a knowledge production system that's
there to explain human diversity it's
the fact that it was and remains to this
day a science its ultimate aim right
it's to produce contingent truths
explanations that are testable and
correctable explanations that are tested
and improved as we increase our
understanding of our origins our biology
and our behavior
so while eugenics scholars were hard at
work at Cold Spring Harbor Yale Harvard
Stanford and elsewhere there were other
science minded scholars who took another
approach towards exploring human
diversity the father of American
anthropology a Polish immigrant named
Franz Boas he's a great example of these
scholars who look beyond biology and
eugenics to understand why some folks
live in igloos while others enjoy indoor
plumbing and
we'll come back to Boaz later in our
course but for now we can get a brief
preview of the idea he offers as an
alternative to the biological
determinism of eugenics advocates while
social Darwinists would argue that one's
biology determines whether or not they
live as primitive or civilized people
Boaz didn't succumb to two foundational
ideas of strict biological determinism
first he did not see culture as the
product of biology instead he looked to
see how one's environment shapes unique
cultural traditions and second because
he looked beyond biology to explain
human diversity he argued that there
really wasn't a specific scientific
basis for ranking people and cultures on
the spectrum of primitive to civilized
people who live in igloos and huts art
less human or civilized than
cosmopolitan New Yorkers they're just
different
equally modern just different not rang
Keable just different I mean in short
rather than ethnocentrically judging the
arctic igloo dwellers is primitive
hunter-gatherers bow and saw them as
uniquely adapted to a very challenging
environment and just as an ice-fishing
inuit man might have trouble figuring
out how to get by in New York City and
urbanite like by Oh a like Boaz if left
to his own devices well he would have
similar problems figuring out how to
feed and shelter himself in the Arctic
Circle I mean think about it when he did
his field research I'm going to Inuit on
Baffin Island his questionable hunting
skills and vulnerability they weren't a
function of Boaz's biology he wasn't
primitive or biologically less evolved
than his Arctic hosts
he was just far from home far far away
ultimately boas learned and taught that
cultures are neither rank able nor
biologically based their relative and as
such people from different cultural
traditions they're equally and fully
human and this idea it's basically what
we call cultural relativity some
cultures aren't better or worse than
others they're just different
so when biological determinants soft
people who look different
live differently from themselves they
ascribe the difference to biology and as
such they divided humanity into
biological races for example 18th and
early 19th century anthropologist who
advocated this position commonly
described our human origins and races in
one of two ways some argued that
Africans Asians and Europeans for
example each had distinct origins
multiple eden so to speak and they
resulted in multiple distinct and
biologically defined races kind of like
you and your next-door neighbors right
you're both human families but you come
from two distinct family lines others
however they theorize that despite the
fact that humanity shares common origins
humankind split into multiple biological
races like the ones we still see listed
in the US census the human genome and
our knowledge of our hominid ancestors
well they definitively refute both of
these theories different skin colors yes
but there's only one race the human race
so if all of our anthropological
evidence tells us that different skin
colors and cultures are manifestations
of one biological race why does the myth
of multiple human races persist my first
response is that it still surprises me
to see how clumsily we all use this term
race I mean the myth of multiple races
endures everywhere I look even
universities institutions of higher
education including the one that I work
for they still use multiple racial
categories on financial aid and
admissions applications I mean think
about this if the first document my
students complete on their path to
graduation is that document that
reinforces the idea of multiple races
well if that's the case anthropologists
like me we're going to have our work cut
out for us
so toward the end of the 20th century
for example the members of the American
Anthropological Association gasped at
the argument put forth by Richard
Herrnstein a psychologist and his
co-author Charles Murray
scientist and their book the bell curve
the author's explored the very question
we've been discussing today they looked
at both genetic and environmental
influences on human diversity and when
they analyzed the connection between
intelligence and what they conceived as
race the controversial authors
ultimately argued that compared with
black Americans both East Asians and
white Americans historically perform
better on IQ tests because of their
biology their distinct genetic heritage
critics and supporters of this argument
fiercely debated these findings and it
wasn't just anthropologist who sharply
challenged terms gene and Murray's
methodology and conclusions my former
colleague mel connor from emory
university who's a harvard trained m.d.
as well as an anthropology PhD he
effectively described why anthropologist
and others like Noam Chomsky and Stephen
Jay Gould fervently refuted the bell
curves conclusions specifically he said
that Murray and Herrnstein presented
strong evidence that genes do play a
role in intelligence but their L dents
in no way supported their theory that
genetics explains the difference between
IQs of black and white Americans
similarly in 1994 the members of the
American Anthropological Association put
forth an official statement on race to
clear up the pervasive myth of multiple
biological races simply put they said
that one all humans are members of a
single species Homo sapiens and two and
I'll use their words here quote
differentiating species and two
biologically defined races has proven
meaningless and unscientific as a way of
explaining human variation and in this
case intelligence put another way the
experts all agree that genetics and
heredity play an important roles in
determining human variation that's a
given but they differ on the question of
whether genetic variation correlates
with conventional racialized
constructions like white versus black
and anthropology
clearly tells us there is no such
correlation we're genetically one race
the human race and its traits like skin
color and intelligence they fail to
actually map onto the racialized
categories most people use to classify
human diversity today but hold on just a
minute before we can fully embrace the
idea that race as we've known it is
indeed a social construct one urgent
question remains if racial categories
like Hispanic and Asian are social
constructs not natural divisions in the
human species if they're not truly
biological categories then how in the
world do anthropologists explain the
existence of pervasive health
inequalities that affect some groups
more than others why to around 40% or
more of African Americans have
hypertension when only 30% of
non-hispanic whites are afflicted with
this condition and why are Native
American populations more than twice as
likely to be diagnosed with diabetes
compared with non-hispanic whites
well anthropologist clarence gravely has
our own answer and his wealth cited
article titled how race becomes biology
embodiment of social inequality gravelly
shows us that race despite being a
social construction it's very real in
terms of socio economic and health
outcomes and those health outcomes good
or bad they're passed on through the
generations
so first gravely shows us that an
individual's exposure to racism over a
lifetime it actually increases one's
risk of infant mortality diabetes stroke
and high blood pressure
not to mention lower life expectancy and
all of these health outcomes they can
definitely impact future generations
mainly because any one of them can
adversely impact both prenatal and
postnatal development and health for
example in the six months following the
events of September 11 2001 the
likelihood that a mother would deliver a
low
wait baby rows by 34 percent actually
let me clarify a 2006 study by Diane
Lauderdale of the University of Chicago
reviewed arab-american birth records and
found that the incidence of low birth
weight deliveries rose 34% for only
women with Arabic names and what gravely
in Lauderdale I want us to think about
here is the cyclical nature of social
inequality and racism if you're an
expecting mother it's clear that from
the womb on your child will feel the
biological impact of racism not race and
apply this generational cycle over and
over and we can begin to under we can
begin to explain high rates of diabetes
and hypertension among black and Native
American populations I mean this is the
biology of racism not the biology of
race gravity's big idea here it's a game
changer and it has implications for how
scientists and health workers classify
human diversity and here's the take home
message racism racial inequality and
xenophobia they become embodied in
biological well-beings of racialized
groups not races groups that have been
racialized remember biologically were
one race homo sapien so in retrospect we
now see how conventional racial
categories are indeed social
constructions and biologically speaking
they're inconsistent with actual
patterns of human genetic diversity that
is until the biological impacts of
racism and inequality take root and
spread into future generations but
remember that's the biology of racism
not the biology of race I mean even the
US Census Bureau which is misused the
term race for centuries now even they
make it clear that when they use the
term race they're not talking biology
here it is this is their clarification
as posted on the official website these
are their words not mine
quote the racial categories included in
the census questionnaire generally
reflect a social definition of race
recognized in this country
and not an attempt to define race
biologically anthropologically or
genetically so let's let's wrap this up
and clear up the enduring ambiguity
associated with the way we understand
the relationship between race and human
variation already in this course we've
identified evidence that reveals our
human origins now let's think about how
our origins and our evolutionary history
critically inform our understanding of
race and human variation first we know
that technically were primates
upright-walking apes to be precise and
we know that the earliest humans split
off from our common ancestors with
contemporary chimpanzees and bonobos
apes and that happened some 7 million
years ago and after that early humans
they found creative solutions to filling
bellies and producing future generations
and in the lectures from unit 1 we
examined the Paleolithic record
including the fossil remains of
ancestors like art of Pittacus and Homo
habilis and this fossil record it
clearly shows us how early humans had
been migrating in and out of africa
populating the planet for some 2 million
years when we added genetics to our
investigation we found that
anthropologists trace modern humanity
back to an original East African
population of early homo sapiens we
shared origins we are one one species
one race the human race now those early
homo sapiens
they migrated near and far from the
equator and eventually through
evolutionary processes variations in
skin merged as did hair types and skull
shapes and more but those variations
were as they say skin deep surface level
different skin colors yes but different
genetic origins absolutely not
we are one one human race